The mathematics behind computer
graphics is fascinating,
especially when it comes to 2D and
3D projection.
Whether you are creating
a side-scrolling platformer or
a first-person shooter,
it turns out that how the graphics
are transformed and manipulated before
they reach the screen is very similar.
As you might expect, 2D can be
considered as just a special case of 3D,
and, in fact,
that's how many frameworks and
development tools treat 2D objects and
scenes.
It's a question of perspective,
literally.
We usually think of perspective
as a feature only of 3D games,
like driving games or
first-person shooters, because they tend
to look like the physical world looks.
There are vanishing points
where lines converge, and
objects appear smaller
the farther away they get.
This is because they rely on perspective
projection to render objects on a flat
screen, but there's another
whole category of projection
called parallel projection that
produces very different results.
In fact, one kind of parallel
projection called orthographic can turn
a 3D scene into a typical platform or
side view or a top-down 2D map.
This allows 2D game
developers to use today's,
powerful feature-rich 3D development
tools, then achieve the look and
feel they want simply by changing
properties of the main camera view.
This is the approach we'll take for
our game.
We'll use an orthographic projection
to render it in the style of a classic
side-view platformer.
Later, you might experiment on your
own with other kinds of projections.
They're fun to play around with.
Isometric projection
is popular right now.
Think of Crossy Road or Monument Valley.
At first glance, it looks like
objects are drawn with perspective,
but then you notice that
there's no foreshortening,
which is a classic feature
of perspective drawing.
One time, in a hare-brained attempt at
optimization, I accidentally created
a rather exotic projection in which
all straight lines curved subtly,
kind of like a fish eye lens,
but not exactly.
I was trying to simplify the math for
speed and
was experimenting with
spherical coordinates.
The result wasn't really practical for
my purposes at the time, but
it found its way into
other projects later on.
It was cool.